[Music]
is there any
i don't know man i'm new to this
universe and so the language is going to
be limiting but
is there brand limitations that y'all
have boxed yourselves into
brand limitations yeah it's weird i was
it's like dave get
dave ramsey getting a credit card he
can't oh right you can't lease a car
sure sure the credit card thing is
because that's a limitation he set up
for himself
right and if his values were to change
around that
and he he could find a way to articulate
that i don't think it ever would it
doesn't make sense for that i mean it's
an absurd
example i'll give you an example though
ryan and i um
we needed new computers recently so ryan
ordered it from the apple store
the one that was close to my house is in
like this giant shopping mall
and i get anxiety going in into shopping
malls but
i go in there and of course seven people
run across me uh what is the minimalist
guy doing in the shopping mall right
it's like oh i'm just buying something
product from a major corporation and
and so in a way it has it keeps me in
check as well because
it doesn't yeah at first it's like well
i i do care what someone else thinks
about me that's a that's a self-esteem
issue right
but really it's like okay are my actions
still aligned with my values because
even though ryan and i are radically
different in terms of personality we're
different on the enneagram we're
different on the myers-briggs stuff like
the
ex exact opposites on myers briggs but
we have the same values we just have
different paths by which to get to those
values
dave and i talk about that a lot we have
very different beliefs
but we have very similar values and in
fact that's why i love reading that's
why i love hanging out with cool
interesting people because
i'm my goal is to change my beliefs
often as i grow up like get new
information learn new things
but i want to keep this tethered to true
values doesn't sound like you're scared
of accountability
and we live in a culture that is
terrified oh yeah
accountability becomes judgment and it
becomes oppressive
i personally need accountability because
i've proven to myself over time i can't
always
walk through life by myself why do we
have problems with it do you think
um i don't know yeah i'm scared to be
called out
there's there may be a shame yeah well
it's i think
we could probably do a whole show on
that i think we
are we are our wiring is i haven't used
machine metaphors but
we are co-regulated with other people to
know where we are
in relationship with other people and i
think
when someone holds us accountable
instead of choosing to hear that as a
way to bring us closer together
it's weaponized see i've already
accepted the fact that i'm a hypocrite
okay i mean we're all hypocrites yeah so
i mean it's it's just
what level of hypocrite are you okay um
i hate slave labor yeah
but i sure love my smartphone ah i don't
love it but i really enjoy it i use it
uh my laptop you know i mean like i
really care about the environment
but man there's a lot of cobalt that's
in my life so i mean
there's there's a little bit of uh what
they call it call it cognitive
dissonance
yes that we all have to live with um
so yeah as we bend the art towards what
does it look like
yeah and then if someone calls me out on
something you know i can look in the
mirror and say
is there a valid point here or
uh is this person just being a seagull
and so here's here like there's a
difference between criticism and
feedback criticism
it's called the seagull effect someone
flies in they like crap on what you do
and then they fly away
they're gonna love that yeah you're like
oh thanks
and then feedback is like it's it's the
problem presented with a solution
and okay so if i can differentiate
differentiate from those two
if someone's trying to hold me
accountable i can you know look at like
is this just criticism or is this
feedback and is it something i
legitimately
need to look at you all have to get
bombarded oh dude
with people deciding their version of
whatever their thing is and
how do you keep you guys insulated how
do y'all stay insulated from that
well i don't read the comments okay
pretty much
yeah it goes back to that should thing
right people
we we've moralized everything in our
culture can i believe in morality but
when it's like
hey you should go to college or you
should own a home at this
age or you should do this you shouldn't
do you should eat that
you shouldn't do that and it's like well
wait a minute
these things right and wrong in most of
these instances they're highly
individual
right because it's about preferences
it's about our own
values and if you have different values
from me then your shoulds are going to
be different than mine
and so there are no universal shoulds in
most of these things that we're talking
about and so
yeah if someone else is sort of heaping
their own values on to me
i think at this point it's fairly easy
to dismiss that yeah yeah
the people who love you let me say it
this way who do you have
who have you given permission to speak
into
hold you accountable oh um i i
i will let anyone hold me accountable
again okay yeah like i don't
i don't there's no one i wouldn't
like just listen to it like if they came
to me they're like ryan so family or
friends like
social media is a different world yeah
yeah but like family and friends i mean
anyone can come to me and
say they have a problem with something
and i have um man i'll tell you when you
call yourselves the minimalists you find
out very quickly who your real friends
are
it's it's really it was really crazy
because yeah you have all this judgment
you're not a minimalist ryan you
snowboard you know i mean she's like all
this stuff coming my way
so yeah um but because she's those are
exactly the same thing
and i don't know i don't know what has
given me this mechanism to
just hold space for other people's
judgments um
but it's just well the first couple
years we did this
it was very difficult like it was um i
just had i guess i've just developed
fixed in
skin over the last you know eight nine
years to where
uh yeah i just i don't let it ruin my
day anymore criticism
only hurts if if the uh praise feels
good
say that again if you need the praise
then the criticism will hurt more
okay if you don't need the praise
then the criticism if you then you don't
care and it's just information then it
is right and so
and then it's less about the
accountability thing in terms of
accountability i often think of the
people i seek out like we have
some great people on our team you met
podcast john and jordan
yeah we got jess and we've got some new
folks who are starting this month and
so we've got a nice core team and
seeking
some sort of accountability from them or
feedback is a way to keep myself
accountable as well i may not always
agree with them
and and that's okay but i can at least
see their perspective
so from from using the minimalist ethos
here
i had a season where i took everybody's
if you had an opinion i was willing to
hear it and if you had a reflection for
me i was
okay let's take it um and especially i
was working in university it was every
student every student's parent
every student's every cultural everybody
had an opinion about how i was doing my
job
and i tried to take them all and it came
ultimately had to say well i've got to
pare this down too
there's about five or about six people
who i'm gonna get permission
to hurt me i'm gonna give five or six
people permission to
have access to my heart and those are
i'll take your criticism i'll take your
you know hey you need to do this better
you're not very good on this show you
need to help
should have done it like i'll take that
all day but a
moral character judgment a you're not
being the person that you said you want
to be
i'm going to take that for fewer people
and it sounds like you're you seek that
out
like we've got a team that you all hire
intentionally or you surround yourself
with
say we're gonna listen to them i think i
think when your actions are
in alignment with your values like
for me uh i don't like nothing i can
look in the mirror like no matter what
anyone says i can look in the mirror and
be like dude
i really like you yeah you know that to
me is the
that's that is yeah that's it right
yeah so you can look in the mirror and
say i like you and if anyone can help me
like myself better then i'm all ears
yes you know but beautiful anything else
that comes my way it's just like
i like i've worked so hard over these
last 10 years so like really i'm not
perfect man you know
but like my short-term actions align
with those those long-term values and
the more you do that the more you like
yourself the less
the less the criticism bothers you
really because you're just tethered to
it right
yeah yeah i realize that your opinion
doesn't matter
yeah i mean you specifically but also
that's the thing like what matters is
the truth right
and and so well that's really ultimately
what i'm trying to get i don't want to
bang my opinion up against yours and
then we're arguing over aesthetics or
or something that is on the edges of
what is the truth
but if we can get beyond the opinion
right and beyond sides it's one of the
most dangerous things we have now we've
created these sort of
bifurcated sides and it's you versus me
we're otherizing other people
and i prefer community community unites
around something tribes unite against
something and so i'd rather have a
community of people who united around
doing some meaning
that's actually why we same side of the
booth this entire thing to show how
unified